South Korea's president said this
morning it is too early to be optimistic
about denuclearization talks with North
Korea president Trump calls the
situation with North Korea tenuous but
he believes Pyongyang is sincere in its
offer to discuss giving up its nuclear
weapons the statements coming out of
South Korea and North Korea have been
very positive that would be a great
thing for the world great thing for the
world so we'll see how it all comes
about Holly Williams is in South Korea
just outside Seoul Holly good morning
good morning North Korea has not
officially confirmed that it's willing
to talk to the US about denuclearization
in return for security guarantees this
is all coming from senior South Korean
officials who made a rare visit to the
north this week
they also say that North Korea's leader
Kim jong-un has agreed to a summit
meeting with the South Korean president
moon jae-in next month the first meeting
between the top leaders of the two
Koreas in over a decade the response
here in South Korea and also the US has
been a mix of very cautious optimism and
downright skepticism because North Korea
has reneged on previous agreements while
its missiles have got better and its
nuclear bombs have got bigger but the
fact that the north wants to talk at all
is almost certainly due to economic
sanctions biting the regime hard the
u.s. is keeping up its so-called maximum
pressure strategy against North Korea
announcing new sanctions yesterday Gayle
thank you very much